president trump meanwhile has made no
mention of the pandemic or the stimulus
bill in days he has instead spent much
of his time on twitter
tweeting out hundreds of unverified
claims of election fraud
while he's been away from the cameras
today mr trump returns hitting the
campaign trail in georgia to lend
support to the two republican incumbents
an important race for the state and the
country chip reid
is at the white house this morning with
the latest chip good morning to you
well good morning president trump will
be in valdosta georgia this evening
where he will rally support for two
republican senators
who face runoff elections one month from
today january 5th
those races are incredibly important
because they will determine which party
controls the united states senate and
many republicans are worried
that the president with his constant
false claims of election fraud in the
presidential election
will depress republican turnout and hand
victory
to the democrats the road to the senate
republican majority runs right
through the state of georgia one day
ahead of president trump's visit to
georgia vice president mike pence
campaigned in savannah
hoping to reignite the president's base
there to vote in the high stakes and
runoff
for republican senators david perdue and
kelly lefler i know we've all got our
doubts about the last election and i
actually hear some people saying
just don't vote
my fellow americans if you don't vote
they win it's massive
that doubt has been partly influenced by
president trump's baseless
claims that he lost georgia due to
fraudulent absentee ballots and
rigged voting machines and he's attacked
georgia's republican secretary of state
brad rafensberger for being complicit as
secretary of state
i believe that the numbers that we have
presented today
are correct the numbers reflect
the verdict of the people he hasn't
looked when he looks he'll see the kind
of evidence that right now you're seeing
in the georgia
senate you know they're going through
hearings right now in georgia and
they're finding tremendous
volumes so they haven't looked very hard
on friday the trump campaign filed a
lawsuit in georgia's
state court against raffensberger and
other state officials
they're asking the court to invalidate
the state's general election results
charging tens of thousands of illegal
votes were cast
president trump said yesterday he'll be
watching those two runoff campaigns very
closely telling reporters quote
we will have our eyes on it like
nobody's ever watched
anything before michelle alrighty chip
thank you